you can set favorite locations in tungle
for visitors to your page to choose from
for example if I want to meet with shaku
I can choose from the locations he set
for
meetings here's how to set it up when
signed into your account click settings
on the left and then location
suggestions click add
location and start
typing you can enter a physical address
boardroom names or even a conference
line to add additional locations click
add location again you'll be able to add
up to
10 be sure to check the box to suggest
these locations to your tongle
visitors when you're happy with your
changes click save changes and you're
done